hello everyone and welcome to the
official live book signing and
q a for the authoritarian moment i am
your host elisha krause and we are here
with the one and only
ben shapiro who's super duper excited to
be here
always always so tonight is a big night
because ben will be answering all of
your questions live for the entire hour
but that's only if you bought a book
not just any book an autographed book so
head on over to dailywire.com
ben to purchase your autographed copy of
the authoritarian moment right now
there will be a text box for you to ask
ben a question at checkout and
you'll also get an email with the same
text box so you can submit a question
at your very own convenience so go
submit your questions now and
ben it's good to see you elisha krause
as i live and breathe
here i am what are you doing in this
state the free state of florida only you
could bring me back to my birthplace i'm
sure this place is great
that and the amazing cuban food it's and
also the freedom yeah
i mean the freedom's nice did you
breathe the air of the freedom did you
come in you're like
humidity it's not good with the skin if
i get un like
really bad oily mega is gonna have to
roll in here it's gonna be a thing you'd
be amazed the amount of money that you
save in taxes
just to fix those problems but not all
of us can be as rich as you sir
well i mean that is an unfortunate
reality of life and you can make ben
richard by buying
i mean i don't understand though how
i've only been here for three days and
i'm more tan
than you and you've lived here for what
like six months now i mean we've known
this for a long time i'm like a vampire
i sparkle in the sun that is my appeal
yes like they open the casket and i just
kind of roll out
like joe biden except less old do you
think vampires are authoritarian
i don't even know where to go with this
all right if you haven't can you
introduce the book to everybody i read
it on the plane out
it was a five hour flight i wish you'd
done the audio version then it would
have been done in like two hours it's
true my wife has the same issue like she
has the opportunity to read all of my
books early and does it never
instead just waits for the audio version
to come out and then she listens to it
yeah in the car
um and because she deals with me on a
regular basis she can listen to me at
two-time speed
so she can knock out the entire book in
like three hours three and a half hours
she's an audible learner she's like i
just
been on normal speed is right also
because if you give my wife a book and
she reads like two pages of it she's out
like a light
really done yeah which is amazing
because she's like as we know a medical
doctor which means she's just
ready to get through medical school um
coffee
yeah so can you introduce the book i
know you've been talking about it on
your show a lot i really enjoyed it i'm
kind of a history nerd
so i appreciated how you went through
like an actual explanation of
authoritarianism
and where we've seen it in history and i
don't want to give anything away yeah so
i mean the basic idea of the book and i
think we all feel it on the right and in
the center and even on the moderate left
is that we feel right now in america as
though all of the institutions are
arrayed against your ability to speak
freely freely and by polling data this
is true if you look at every subgroup
politically in the united states with
the exception of people who consider
themselves far left
every single subgroup in the united
states feels as though they are unable
to speak freely they're going to be met
with social ostracization
they're going to be met with their
bosses yelling at them or maybe them
losing their jobs
they're going to be crowd mobbed on on
facebook or twitter
they're going to be sort of unpersoned
online uh and they might even be excised
from sort of normal everyday activities
people won't talk to them people won't
patronize their business
now these this this move is somewhat
unique in modern american history for
sure
and the extent of it is really unique
and that is because all of these
institutions which we sort of took for
granted as neutral
have now been as i talked about in the
book renormalized basically a small
group of people
have taken over these institutions and
because there are a lot of people in the
middle who
are conflict diverse and and didn't want
to get in fights they basically said
okay to that
and the result is that virtually every
major institution in american life
whether you're talking about the media
or the talk about social media whether
you're talking about entertainment
scientific institutions as we're now
seeing with the cdc whether you're
talking about the military i mean i was
a shocker i think i'm not sure how many
conservatives thought that the military
is going to be wilkified but that
apparently is now on the way
you're seeing it in virtually every
institution of american life
the renormalization of these
institutions and then weaponization of
the institutions to tell you to shut up
and exercise you from from
american life and i think the audience
has a fear that i kind of have too as
we've seen and you've been talking about
on your show how democrats are now using
the government
and everything else and the media is
going along with it
and and i think the major question is
how do we fight it like on a small scale
and a broader scale so i think
there are a couple of things that we can
do uh one is that we can
you know take the sort of conservative
approach to this and we can create
alternatives so that's what we did at
daily wire
you're seeing this happen in a wide
variety of businesses that's not
actually my preferred solution my
preferred solution is that we
push a lot of these businesses
particularly corporate you know the
corporate world
back into neutrality i think that we
need neutral spaces i think sports ought
to be a neutral space and entertainment
ought to be a neutral space
if that's not going to happen we have to
create alternatives if we are going to
take back institutions and
re-renormalize them like make them
normal again then what that's going to
require
is an actual cohesive concerted move so
to understand
how to do that we sort of have to
understand how these institutions got
there in the first place
the the basic idea is that these
institutions ended up left-wing because
you had a small group of very motivated
and intransigent people and they went to
everybody in the middle and they said
listen if you just give us what we want
we'll shut up we'll leave you alone
and a lot of people in the middle went
oh okay and you see this happen like
every day in your family
there's one person in your family who
just loves the vegan analogy
yes i mean not to give it away and not
to dump on no it's fine who we both know
and love is vegan
but i mean listen i i i understand
veganism and i kind of have some vegan
tendencies except the meat tastes
amazing but the
but the the vegan analogy is one put
forward by a niece
nicholas talib and his basic analogy you
have a family of four
one member of the family says usually
the daughter says i'm vegan now and now
the entire family
has a choice right mom has a choice when
she makes dinner that night she says
i can either make two meals one for
everybody else and one for the vegan kid
or we're all eating vegan tonight and
then you take that family you put them
in a block party with four other
families and the family says listen
we're all eating vegan because of
little jessica over here and so we're
going to eat vegan
you know you're free to cook meat or you
can just make vegan for everybody but we
need vegan yeah and so now the hostess
of the party has to figure out okay do i
cook vegan for everybody or do i make
two separate meals which is more of a
pain in the butt
and so now you've had one person
renormalize 20 people everybody's eating
a big announcement and you see this
routinely throughout institutions you'll
have a small group of people
at an institution who say you know what
we need diversity training and the
diversity training we need
but is diversity so bad diversity is
good right i mean like why are you
anti-diversity
and if you don't go along with us on
this then we're going to shout that
you're racist and we're going to go to
the new york times and we're going to
have them call you racist
and that is going to have a marked
impact on how the public sees your
business
and so corporate heads tend to cower in
fear over this you see this with
advertisers all the time right
advertisers are constantly getting two
three tweets and suddenly
they freak out it's like well that's two
people who are upset but the reason
they're upset
is because they have an internal group
of employees who don't like that they're
advertising in the first place on a wide
variety of sources
and they understand that those employees
will eventually go to the media and it
takes some actual corporate
stones to say to your own employees no
we're not doing any of that so we do
want to get to people's questions which
is really exciting again if you haven't
bought the book yet head on over to
dailywire.com
to purchase your autograph copy of this
really cool book
right here it's only 30 i mean it's not
gonna make him that much richer but
it'll make you a lot more educated and
happy
and entertaining and then you can
trigger some liberals on your summer
vacation it's a great deal
and you're getting ben's signature you
can go and also ask your have your
questions answered live tonight
over the next hour and if your question
is not answered don't worry you're still
going to get your autographed copy of
the book
and we have some fun things planned for
you tonight but
we're going to kick get it kick things
off
you guessed it with an authoritarian
moment
i did not see that coming is this your
boot well i did not see that coming
all right so right now what we have
oh here we go this clip is from 1933
and a parade was held for the promotion
of the national recovery
administration we're gonna roll the clip
in september 1933 the government
sponsored a spectacular parade of new
york's fifth avenue
to promote an unprecedented federal
effort
the national recovery administration
roosevelt called the nra a partnership
in planning between government and
industry
its goal to speed recovery by
establishing profit levels for business
and wage levels to labor in a show of
national solidarity more than two
million employers across the country
promise to abide by the nra codes
[Music]
alrighty thoughts on that authoritarian
moment yes i mean
the the sort of background to that for
folks who don't know is that in the
middle of the great depression
fascism was kind of the wave so
mussolini was considered actually
in pretty good odor by by a large swath
of the left in the united states the
same thing was true of stalin
and even hitler i mean hitler was
featured as time magazine's man of the
year
in 1936 the the walter durantes of the
world were still going over to the
soviet union and talking about how
wonderful things were over there
and general goldberg talks about this at
length in in his book liberal fascism
but the nra was the federal government
saying to private businesses
we need you to put up this patriotic
symbol in your window and this is how we
know that you are abiding
by our request for you to limit your
profit and also give certain wages
to particular people and there is actual
governmental pressure to the market
saying like only shop at places that are
showing you this special sign this blue
eagle which is
really creepy and authoritarian for sure
i also kind of feel
like we're going that way down the
slippery slope with the cdc regulations
of like where you are allowed to and not
go
but i'm sure we'll have some questions
related to that and if you are just
tuning in
this is another reminder that in order
to purchase a signed copy of ben's new
book the authoritarian movement you can
head on over to dailywire.com
ben so let's sign some books give some
hard-working
well-paid people here at the daily wire
who uh got these ready
i'm so tempted to sign one just but i
don't want to disappoint poor christina
in terrytown new york be like
who the heck is elisha kraus and why did
she sign ben shapiro's book
so she wants to say ask you this
question thanks to our mainstream media
asking joe biden
real hard-hitting questions we now know
that his favorite flavor of ice cream is
chocolate chocolate chip
what is your go-to ice cream flavor wow
uh so
carvel is the big thing out here um and
so carvel does have
uh a cake batter flavor that is
excellent it's like a cookie butter
flavor also that one's really good i'm
big into ice cream they also have like a
uh toffee alcohol flavored
thing that's that's excellent wait what
you like alcohol now i like alcohol
flavor i'm still not i'm still a child
i'm gonna say how florida has changed
you
well i mean i always drink florida
drinks right i always have like the pina
colada and i look like 16
basically this is my place where i'm
like an eight-year-old jew who drinks
pina coladas on the beach
like yeah you've known me long enough to
know that like i was always a fl i was
always florida man
it was just a question of time all
righty this next
question comes from sean sean ben is
going to sign your book right now
he's in newbernburg oregon he says it
seems like a lot more people have woken
up to the current authoritarian trend
however most people seem to be remaining
silent like you had mentioned people are
afraid of speaking out right
what do you think it will take for more
people to start speaking up while
everyone else
seems afraid to do so the big thing is a
feeling of momentum there always have to
be a few people who step out front and
then mobilize everybody else because the
the dike has been breached and now you
know there can sort of be a movement
you saw this with critical race theory
it took a few parents to get up and
start saying things that's a receive a
lot of media attention a lot of other
people got up and they said oh wow there
are people who agree with me
one of the things that the sort of
conspiracy of silence that has occurred
on social media and in the media with
regards to dissenting views has done
is make you feel like you are by
yourself like you are alone uh
like you're in a vast minority friend's
posting all these hashtags
it's right exactly it's black square
time all of your friends are gonna be
it's pride month you have to post the
rainbow pride flag or something
and if you don't do it then you are
definitely on the outs with all of your
friends and family
and if you say listen i really don't
like this is my thing then you're by
yourself
because you've done something wrong but
the treatment is violence your silence
is violent well they didn't
this is one of the points i make in the
book they morphed the left has more from
be polite right just don't say anything
that's super offensive to
speech is violence and if you say
something that offends me you've
actually committed an act of violence
upon me to silence his violence which is
you must mirror every single thing i say
and if you do not you have done an act
of violence
to me but i think the bottom line is
that we have to create a feeling that
there are a bunch of other people who
think like you and i think that's one of
the things that the book is pointing out
if you think that you're in the minority
because you think that men are men and
women are women
you are not that is a majority position
in the united states if you think that
you're in the minority
because you don't believe that the
united states is inherently racist or
that the institutions of the united
states were founded in racism or that
the cops are racist
if you think that that's a minority that
is not a minority position that is a
majority position
it's just that you've been told by all
of these institutional players who
control your means of
garnering information that that's just a
fringe these are not fringe positions
these are majority positions but back to
sean's question
who does it take to step out and say
something in order for people like shawn
and others who are
using jane doe when they ask ben shapiro
a question on
public internet because they're afraid
of the ramifications who does it take
you have to organize inside your own
company i mean what this really requires
is collective action you need
yeah if you you need basically 10 to 20
of your company to mobilize with you
so find people with whom you can have
solidarity it's a hundred percent
company see if you can find 50 or 20
other people who agree with you
and then do exactly what the left does
write a letter to the to the people who
run the company
and say you know what we're not even
asking for you to mirror our political
priors all we're asking for is
neutrality and once
the people at the top of the company
realize there's somebody pushing back
neutrality would be the
sort of default position that they
should be seeking all right next
question is william in virginia beach
virginia great town
he wants to ask do you see the
republican party ever winning back the
majority in virginia or are we just
screwed here
uh i think that the republican party is
going to do shockingly well in virginia
this election cycle i think that the
virginia government is pushing nearly
every radical policy i can think of and
that legislature is
not solid blue that is that is a it's a
blue legislature but not by much it's
still fairly narrow
in virginia and let's recall that they
have had republican governors
fairly recently uh and so the the the dc
suburbs have turned virginia a lot more
blue obviously
but as the dc as the sort of virginia
legislature starts to push anti-gun
stuff and pro-abortion stuff and as they
start to push critical race theory stuff
there's going to be blow back one of the
one of the mitigating factors that has
allowed democrats to gain ground in
places like virginia
is that virginia is a very suburban
state donald trump really underperformed
in the suburbs but
he's not on the ballot anymore and this
is a real problem for democrats come
2022 and 2024.
yeah you talked about that a little bit
on your show today the breakdown of oh
are all these anti-vaxxed people really
donald trump voters
and maybe it's just mainstream
democratic party's gonna have to figure
out how to
you know win those people back all right
next question is for andrew in
millport new york he wants to know how
can he co-parent with someone that has
completely opposite political views as
me
and a totally different outlook on the
world and how to raise a child
andrew what did you do i would what did
you what did you do
right exactly let's start from the
beginning here so
you skipped my first piece of marital
advice which is do not marry somebody
who does not share your values but
if you if you didn't then you're going
to have to find some deeper values the
elisha
uh and those values don't necessarily
have to be center of top line political
in nature those can be values like you
value freedom of speech and
intelligence of aids and you value data
right you can go to kind of vague
concepts that you can agree on
and then you have to make a deal with
each other which is that you are not
going to argue with each other about
politics in front of the kids
right that it it's it's not good for
kids to believe that their parents are
arguing with each other
all the time especially about sort of
world events in world view because all
it's going to do is is confusing you can
have a discussion that's fine
but if it gets heated then you really
like
protect your kids right this is about
your kids it's not about you all right
next question comes from
dom in chesterfield new jersey what
career path does one take when pursuing
a degree in constitutional law
he says thank you and god bless you and
your family sir that's very nice okay so
uh there's not really such a thing as a
degree in constitutional law per se
there's a law degree
and then you can sort of specialize in
constitutional i can take special
classes in that you can theoretically
get a phd
uh in in sort of constitutional history
but when you go to law school it's not
as though you graduate as a tort lawyer
you just graduate as a lawyer and then
you go work
in a particular sphere unless you're
searching for a phd uh that
that's sort of the answer there okay
next question question comes from cole
in missouri he says hey ben
how will actors be able to be a part of
the upcoming future of daily wire
productions like your shows and films
etc so we are going to be doing casting
calls we are going to be doing auditions
for all of this sort of stuff
i know that we are already in production
on a new film like as of right now
and they actually were in production on
two new films as of right now so
um you know we'll we'll put out the
casting call when and when and if we
require
additional cast right now uh a lot of
the films that we're pursuing tend to be
smaller cast they're not like casts of
of thousands um but
uh we're definitely gonna be doing that
not not quite yet
one day you guys could be the marvel of
the conservative film world i mean first
the marv
i mean the marvel of the marvel film
world is starting to suck did you see
black widow
no yeah it's not good it's a bad it is
not good first the first half hour is
kind of good and then
and then it falls apart i just i wasn't
interested just based on the trailer
which is really sad because i loved her
storyline
in the last two eventually i mean so
first of all they were supposed to bring
it out before the last adventure
before she was dead yeah now it's kind
of awkward because she's dead yeah but
what's weird about that is that she died
in a fall right in infinity war she dies
falling down
and um in black widow she falls from
everything it is possible to fall from
and is totally fine and
unharmed so i know what it was about
like the cliff in infinity war
that was like it was the planet yeah it
was like it was extraordinary
i don't know like bigger plan but
whatever it is like that is the only
fall that has ever hurt her and it
didn't just hurt her it killed her
because in this film she falls off she
goes through two separate car crashes
where the car flips over and lands on
the roof she climbs out she's fine she
goes she like
falls off an actual roof that's like
four stories high
she just gets up brushing herself up and
walks away in infinity war like
they should have killed her in a
different way because it's really
inconsistent interesting all right there
you go
come here to hear political thoughts
from ben stick around for the marvel
movie critiques the next question
is from craig second craig tonight from
milwaukee wisconsin
what is one fun memorable moment that
you have growing up i'm going to take a
wild guess and it has something to do
with baseball maybe
okay so yeah why don't i do a baseball
story so i have a bunch when i was good
but this is a good baseball story so
um i'm 10 years old my dad is coaching
my little league team
and i have two cousins one of whom is on
the team one of whom is coaching
and our team was good we won the the
little league jewish championship that
year which let me tell you is like
winning i thought you were gonna say
your team sucked
oh no i'm actually my expectation i'm
actually a pretty good baseball player
or at least i was when i was 10.
and uh and so there was one team that
was really heavily favored to beat us
and so my dad on the way to the game
he turns to us we're in the car it's a
toyota tercel no air conditioning from
1993 or something
and uh and he says if we win today i'm
taking you guys out and getting a beer
and i'm 10. my cousin's 11. my other
cousin's like 13.
and so we go out we play the game it's
like 95 degrees out and somebody forgot
to bring water
right there's no water for the whole
game oh my gosh we win the game eight to
five
and on the way back my dad just pulls
into like the the supermarket parking
lot and he parks and we're like what are
you doing he's like well we're getting
beer
anyway okay so he takes us inside he
turns to my 13 year old cousin yeah
and he's like what kind of beer do you
want and my cousin's like i like history
how about sam adams
so my dad buys like a six-pack of sam
adams we drive up into the hollywood
hills like where there are no houses
and he breaks open like three of the
beers he doesn't drink
he breaks open three of the beers for us
he gives each one of us a beer
my my older cousin takes one sip he says
it tastes terrible yeah not interesting
i had about like one third of the beer
yeah you know beer does not taste good
right it's not like
you have to be kind of an adult to
appreciate beer except if you're my 11
year old cousin
my cousin who's like one year older was
a big kid and he takes it in like three
goals like the entire beer because he
was thirsty
right he had anything decent enough beer
on a hot day actually tastes great right
starting
you know it's amazing exactly so it's
it's we're frying there's no air
conditioning in the car and it's 95
degrees out so my cousin just downs the
entire beer in like three gulps
and then my dad is like okay we're going
to go home now we start driving we're on
the freeway and suddenly we look over
and realize that my cousin joel
has the beer bottle out the window of
the car he's just waving the beer bottle
around
and my dad's like joel get it that got
the beer bottle
in here i'm gonna get arrested and so
we're all tackling joel in the backseat
so yeah
good times that is hilarious i call your
dad papa socks
my dad's the best because you know you
guys are white soccer yeah that's right
like
those type of stories just make me love
him even my dad is the best server loves
my dad
all right this question comes from hayla
i hope i'm saying
your name right from bay city michigan
beautiful state especially in the summer
time
who is your favorite authoritarian
leader to educate
leftists about because they seem to just
always idolize them
um well you know it's kind of hard
because
when you talk about people who are full
authoritarians the closest thing that
we've had in the united states so a full
authoritarian leader was woodrow
wilson and the left is beginning to have
a rethink on woodrow wilson not because
they cared about the authoritarianism
mainly because he's a racist and so we
which is true he was a vicious horrible
racist
also he was a radical authoritarian who
literally arrested his political
opponents took control of like the
entire economy of the united states
and radically shifted the definition of
how the government was supposed to deal
with the individual citizens so
he was a horrible leader one of the
worst presidents of all time and it's
been amazing to see the historic
recapitulation of his role
so he went for it like 15 years ago if
you took a poll of historians because
historians
are congenitally biased for presidents
who quote unquote do things who are
active
woodrow wilson was always a top 10
president for historians like 10 years
ago
now he's like a bottom 20 president for
historians
and that's not because they've re
they've kind of re-looked at the fact
that he was kind of in favor of eugenics
and the fact that
he shut down free speech and all that uh
they're really pissed at him because he
was a racist that's that's the one
single factor
analysis that we do now of a president
and it's a very important factor it is
it is there are many other reasons why
woodrow wilson is one of the worst
presidents of all time alrighty so he's
the one that you should educate all of
your left-leaning friends about when it
comes to authoritarianism and i don't
know if you're a brave soul
you could go to dailywire.com ben and
buy them a signed copy of his book
right you could it's a good way to test
your friendships this
thomas he's in belgium they got some
good beer over there
send us some thomas pretty please have
you ever considered doing a comparison
of the united states and eu politics uh
i've talked about it sort of
tangentially a little bit uh there are
some pretty wide differences between
american-style conservatism
and uh european style conservatism
particularly so the left in europe
looks very much like the social
democratic left looks very much like the
democratic party here in the united
states although the democratic party in
the united states
is now actually exporting really weird
radical policies to the eu to the extent
that you now have
sort of mainstream center or left
figures in the eu going we don't want
any of that
right you have emanuel macron in france
going we don't want any of your world
crap don't bring that over here
you're starting to see that in britain
too and it's really fascinating to see
that we have now outstripped the
europeans in terms of radicalism because
it used to be all of their bad ideas
ended up over here you'd have
progressivism starting in germany in the
1890s suddenly it makes its way over
here
or existentialism in the 30s making its
way over here um but uh now i guess we
export all of our bad ideas over there
the big distinction between
conservatives there are conservatives
here is conservatives there look a lot
more like these sort of
nationalist populists here they're kind
of like tucker carlson in terms of
politics
uh whereas conservatives traditionally
in the united states have been much more
small government libertarian minded
alrighty this question comes from
aaron who is in tipton west midlands
united kingdom what a foreigner is that
like is that like city
county and country i don't know i think
so all right he says hey ben
what advice would you give a fellow
libertarian conservative
running in their school elections where
most of the electorate are quite liberal
and do you think turning a bit squishy
in the messaging would help the campaign
um i i tend to think not
uh i think that it depends on what you
mean by squishy so the nice thing about
being quote unquote conservative
libertarian is that you have a really
good pitch and the pitch is
stop being a jackass and bothering other
people right that is the pitch for
conservative libertarians
it's it's you guys want to boss
everybody else around and bother
everybody else and i don't want to do
that so
i don't know why you can't leave me
alone and i can't leave you alone and
for young people it's a pretty good
pitch
because young people mainly want to be
left alone to do whatever it is that
they
want to do uh and so i i don't think
that you have to water down that
particular message
okay all right so it looks like we might
have
another authoritarian moment coming up
dang god that freaks me out every time
is this your boat it is not okay i don't
even know what size this is
this one is another authoritarian moment
but this time it's from a different
country not the united states from
russia
circa 1945 and a parade held man these
authoritarians and their parades men
do you love their parade do you love
their military parades usually held
after the defeat of germany
in world war ii
russia hails victory in moscow's red
square during her may day parade
above the tomb of lenin stands marshall
stalin taking the salute from a great
cavalcade of soviet military strength
american officers are guests at the
ceremony watching famous katusha rocket
guns on trucks made in the usa
all right so can you break down what was
happening there yeah i mean that's the
end of world war ii obviously and that
is the brief moment in time when the
united states thought that the russians
were
were our allies which lasted for
approximately two and a half seconds
um because there's a good case to be
made uh that the russians actually
started world war ii
that that it was the ussr i mean the the
molotov uh ribbon trough pact really
began world war ii
and without the backing of the soviet
union there's very little chance that
the
the germans turn and wheel and and
strike the west so
uh the stalin's got gotten off pretty
easy in sort of the
the historical analysis of who are the
worst dictators of all time
male got off super easy right if you
like if you have to rank worst
dictators of all time there's a solid
case that mao is actually number one
considering the number of people
that he killed um and uh and that stalin
is number two and the hitler's number
three and that's coming from somebody i
am no hitler fan let me tell you
hitler not great but hit like if you're
gonna rank these people you don't have
to they can say they all
are evil and horrific because they were
but in terms of long lasting impact on
the world stalin was a much more
effective dangerous and uh and
threatening mass
murderer over the course of you know
decades right i mean he ruled the soviet
union from the 20s all the way through
the
through the mid 50s basically as opposed
to hitler who was in charge of germany
from 1933 until essentially 1945
and um and whose defeat resulted at
least in the liberation of half of
europe
as opposed to everywhere stalin put his
boots that place ended up being a
repressive hell hole
alrighty hence the reason why if you buy
your signed copy
of the book it's like very simple but
good cover art because it works i think
because you talk about like
i drew it myself i did not you oh i
would have i wouldn't be surprised if
you told me your daughter did she's
talented she is talented
but because i don't have a drunk jackpot
there's a reason why we have the
the phrase of like under the heel of
because
too many times in world history there
have been so many authoritarians
this is one of the few times when they
actually asked me like for ideas on
cover art
and i said a jack boot because the
phrase that came to mind is the is the
old orwell phrase that
it's just a boot stamping on the human
face forever from 1984
and that is what i think people are
feeling like in a soft fashion obviously
but it's it's growing and it's getting
worse and you are starting to see
institution people feel so put upon by
their institutions and it's it's story
after story day after day
on topics that used to seem really
non-controversial and now if you say
basic statements of fact you're afraid
that you are going to be unpersoned
and that's that is a deeply disturbing
situation
absolutely next question comes from
patrick in colorado springs colorado
that reminds me of my adventures in
odyssey days as a child
all right how does the right fight
against the weaponization
of the population movement um so i i'm
trying to figure out exactly what they
mean by weaponization of population
movement
i i guess what they presumably mean is
the left trying to
move populations either from abroad or
at home within the within the country to
try and change the politics
so i'm not a big believer that
immigration
per se is a threat to the united states
i think that
the united states is a sovereign country
we get to determine whether people
entering the country add to or detract
from the country
i'm generally very pro-immigration but i
think that we ought to you know make
sure that the people who are entering
the country
are presumed to share our values and and
so the idea that we're going to
bring people in who don't share our
values for any reason doesn't seem like
a net win for the citizens of the united
states
as far as population movement inside the
country right now the sort of big sort
that's happening where
people who are blue are staying in blue
states and people who are right are
leaving i'm not sure that's bad for the
country frankly i mean i think that it's
it's bad
long-term um it's better if the country
you live next door to somebody who you
disagree with and you can still share a
country but as the left gets more and
more
uh authoritarian as i say in the book um
yeah i think that
people who are you know oriented toward
conservatism have a very good case for
leaving i mean i will say quality of
life is radically improved for my family
not living in a heavily blue area i
think also
at what point will the mainstream media
be unable to hide their
uh detest for uh red states well
states continue to do so well and blue
states continue to fail
at a certain point reality is going to
set in for some of these blue states
you're starting to see it in california
with the recall of newsom right there
they're like seven republicans
in california by comparison with the
democrats i mean they're still the most
republicans of any state because it's a
huge state but
by comparison i mean republicans control
nothing in the government anywhere
across the state of california basically
and and newsome is going to get recalled
because democrats are not good at
governing
we're going to do it it's going to be
lots of fun this next question comes
from matt in manheim
pennsylvania he says he's a 20 year old
law enforcement veteran
who is completing his doctorate and he
wants to add
himself to the best list of doctors i am
hoping to break into academia to teach
criminal justice and we talk about
changing the culture in academia but
don't have a direction on how to begin
so do you have any advice on how to
begin the process first you have to find
a faculty advisor who's actually going
to allow you to write on topics that are
controversial and this is a hard thing
one of the things that's happened in the
university system is that the university
system basically
creates the self-perpetuating elite
where professors who are left-wing tend
to approve
thesis theses that are that are
left-wing and so you have to find
somebody who's willing to oversee your
thesis if it happens to be a right-wing
thesis
and then the reality is that you can do
an awful lot
with a position at not even a
particularly prestigious college there
are a lot of professors
in sort of the conservative movement who
are famous and have done
extraordinary work from purchase at not
particularly
well-known colleges the one of the you
know sort of criminal justice minds who
comes to mind right now is wilfred riley
who teaches at eastern kentucky
university it's not
an ivy league school but the work that
he's doing is deeply important
and and i think that you know from a
perch at a university you can do a lot
of a lot of good
all right this question comes from scott
in irvine scotland
scott in scotland how do we prevent
institutions from becoming weaponized in
the future
so the the unfortunately the only way to
do this would be to either
have everybody understand weapons down
or we just have mutually assured
destruction those are the only two
options
right now there's this kind of wing of
the conservative movement that's like
well we should never use mutually
assured destruction you know
let them be the bad guys and we'll be
the good guys and we'll sit over here
and get our butts kicked
and and that's not a good strategy at a
certain point we have to convince the
left
that the best thing to happen here is to
go back to neutrality with these
institutions and if they don't
then we're going to do to these
institutions what they do in
to the institutions because we can't
just sit there and allow them to run
roughshod
over purportedly neutral institutions
and then turn those against us
we just can't do that all right next
question comes from my home state
and it is eric in yukon oklahoma do you
believe that a conflict between china
and the united states will actually
happen
and do you have a prediction of the
outcome of such a conflict
it's hard to imagine an open military
conflict between the united states and
china directly
i think what is much more imaginable is
some form of proxy war
in taiwan uh or some form of proxy war
in the south china sea
and china does not want to get into a
shooting war with the united states
because we will win
uh we we still do have significantly
more military firepower
we're the greatest military force in the
history of the world still
and china knows that um but what china
also understands that we are really
really reticent to use force with regard
to china and
they've got a lot of our corporations
over a barrel because we opened our
markets
to them and they opened their markets
conditionally
to our corporations uh and so i think
that the most likely scenario is a
gradual ratcheting up of tensions
the possibility of a shooting more
exists but it'd be mainly if if there is
a mistake of intent right where china
thinks okay well if we move on taiwan
militarily the u.s isn't going to do
anything
and then the u.s feels that it's its
line has been crossed and the u.s
responds in kind
but uh and that is why it's it's so
ridiculous that the west has
has basically done nothing in the face
of chinese predation like now would be
an excellent time to start severing
economic ties with china and if that
costs americans money
frankly i think americans are kind of up
for it considering the chinese just
unleash a virus that has killed at least
4 million people worldwide including 600
thousand americans
yep all right next question comes from
tyler who is at mcguire air force base
he says
with the power that social media has is
and as it continues to grow
do you think that there will be a time
in the future in which it becomes
regulated by the federal government and
if so what are your thoughts on that
i'm deeply afraid that it will become
regulated by the federal government
there are a couple of different ways
that you could theoretically regulate
social media one is a not bad way and
one is a horrific way
this is why when you see people like oh
the left and the right they agree social
media ought to be regulated no they they
do not actually the left would like
elizabeth warren to sit over social
media and determine what good content
looks like
and i think that for the most part
people on the right would like for
social media
to go hands off in terms of policing
quote unquote misinformation because we
just don't trust their standards
as to what misinformation constitutes i
think that as i've suggested before
maybe the proper solution is to get rid
of what's called the catch-all clause in
section 230 of the communications
decency act
uh that would probably be the best sort
of policy solution there's not
widespread agreement for that however
i just i can't see given the amount of
ire that social media has drawn
uh that there won't be a president of
some party who just in order to get the
win
does something in terms of policy that
ends up centralizing more power in the
federal government the solution to
failures of social media is not to give
the idiots who staff the federal
government more power
oh and it's always i always tell people
think of the shoe on the other foot yeah
like you might like it when biden's in
there but you ain't gonna like it if
it's somebody else
but yeah only right this question comes
from luke in pensacola florida who says
hey
ben welcome to florida i know you've
said you're not interested in public
office but
we could really use your help filling
the shoes of governor desantis when he
wins the presidency in 2024
hey name it claim it man name it claim
it please and thank you love your stuff
oh i mean from your mouth to god's ears
with regard to governor desantis he
would be an excellent president he's an
excellent governor
um why would i ever run for office that
sounds absolutely horrendous you make
less money
wait are you kidding like how many
people are buying books right now
like like right this very instant how is
this possible i mean it's incredible
but also also like uh the the reality is
that that campaigning and asking people
for money and having to shade my message
because i want to win office and like
i've worked at a 501c3 and going to
people and asking them for money is
really uncomfortable and really kind of
terrible
and then if you win then you go live
in tallahassee right which is like
okay i guess but not not his love for
the sunshine state only goes so far
folks well i mean
what kosher restaurants are there in
tallahassee how do i even eat how am i
doing i'm just like
picking lettuce out of the garden your
assistant would be like flying you in
kosher food on your jet and then it
would be a whole thing no but
we just established i'm way just
established i'm way less rich
if i'm a politician so yeah alrighty
then i mean you can go the mitt romney
route and fund your own campaigns and
here's the good news i'm 37 years old so
if in 30 years i decided to run for
president i will still be the youngest
person running for president so
i 30 years of money making and then and
my kids growing up and then we can talk
about it all right this question comes
from new south wales australia
the question comes from adrian who says
considering that the left runs
most organizations and institutions at
what point do you think the right will
be proactive
in their political approach rather than
playing catch-up i have the same exact
question girl
also when the timing is appropriate
given the current pandemic would you
consider coming to australia to do a
special so i think the answer is right
now i think the right is getting much
more active
and then as far as coming to australia i
would love to come to australia if they
ever open up again
yeah i mean it is incredible they're
shutting down australia now for like
four cases of covet this is
nuts i mean the the book i really focus
i do have a chapter on the perversion of
science in the book
about the the attempt to turn science as
a process into science as
the institution and then the use of
science as an institution to just push
forward a bunch of crap that is
completely anti-scientific which is what
you're seeing with regard to covid
and masking policy and lockdown policy
again
but i mean the the actual governmental
authoritarianism that we are now seeing
and being accepted
by heretofore free peoples people being
like yeah you know i understand that
there's no science to back this but sure
i'm still going to mask up in front of
my children or i'm going to mask my
children
or what if we all just lock down here
because there's one case of covet like
what are we are we that fearful of
regular life that we
that we're willing to give this much
power to idiot bureaucrats like these
people can't even tie their own shoes
and you're telling them they can rule
your life has anyone ever met a
politician be like man i wish that guy
were in charge of my bank account not a
single human being has ever had this oh
man
that that guy who's my congressman i
can't wait to have him come over and
babysit my kids not a single human being
has ever had that thought
and yet we're like what if they just
told us how to handle our bank account
or tell us how to raise our kids how
about no how about no to all of this
garbage
all right the next question comes from
oliver who is in melbourne australia
man you got lots of aussie fans that's
super cool who says dear ben
how important is it that the united
states keeps its strong relationships
with countries like their home
in australia when it comes to issues
such as china and
other international events taking place
in the indo-pacific hugely important so
people neglect the fact that australia
is super duper close to china
and that the the western country that is
actually feeling the heat the most right
now is australia
china has threatened to cut off business
ties it has threatened to close shipping
lanes to australia australia is
an ally japan is an ally we have a lot
of allies in that region there are
things that we can do there
uh yeah frankly i think that that
re-entering some form of the
trans-pacific partnership which was
actually a trade
bloc that was directed against the
chinese would be it would be a good
thing but
yeah i mean australia needs to stand
strong and we need to be right behind
them for sure
all right so the next question comes
from elissa i hope elisa
in myriad of california what is one of
your favorite fictional books or book
series that's a good one oh man i have
so many
fiction books that i absolutely adore uh
the one that i actually just bought a
signed autographed copy of a book uh
that's uh it was in
a copy of fahrenheit 451 by bradbury
which i think is just a masterwork
uh and it's so it's so well read
that it's actually underrated right this
happens sometimes there's a movie that's
been seen so many times that
people like such a great movie and then
you watch it like it actually is a great
movie right wizard of oz is one of those
movies where
people are like it's one of the great
movies of all time it's so unbelievable
and then
everybody watches it and you forget how
good it is then you watch it again
you're like oh this is a tremendous film
same thing with the fahrenheit 451 uh as
yeah
all the russians are great and
depressing uh the uh
mark twain is fantastic i'm a big fan of
herman melville's writing
harper lee is great i mean skill
mockingbird is fantastic there are a
couple of more obscure books that i
really like and always recommend if
you're looking for
an obscure novel a a depressing but
wonderful obscure novel is called every
man dies alone by a guy named hans
filata
which is about a couple resisting the
nazis in like 1941 germany
uh and the and the other book is a book
called the secret of santa vitoria which
is also a world war ii book but like
much more
enjoyed by a guy named robert creighton
who's a big best seller they made a
movie out of it with anthony quinn
and it's it's a really really fun read
it's a great book are you
like read the book before you watch the
movie guy always yeah
so i recently this year and our friend
bethany mandel in our homeschooling
curriculum
read uh the nathaniel bowditch which is
a good and apparently was one of the
first disney films but it's not the
t-plus
my girls why was it was it racist or
something no i don't know i think or is
it not racist and they call it racist
like lady and the
probably actually all right next
question comes from jk
in nashua new hampshire hey ben will the
dodgers regret having spent so much
money
on the mookie bets contract i don't i
don't do sports ball guys so i hope i'm
saying that name right
you didn't say you did it right uh yes
okay i mean yes
they spend an awful lot of money on how
much time did they spend oh what was it
250 million
or something something like that it was
an unbelievable amount of money
now listen the doctor's still good team
i mean they're not going to like go
bankrupt
but it's it but yeah they spend a lot of
money on that contract
and how are your socks doing i know my
songs are good this year really yes
they're good and they have a lot of a
lot of guys on the dl they're coming
back off the deal
uh they're the best pitching staff in
the majors
the disabled list oh okay all right next
question comes from
jack in wesley chapel florida hello he
has a couple of questions
you only get one book though okay jack
what's in your opinion the most damaging
thing
to america the abide the biden
administration has done so far
and secondly do you think that trump has
a better shot of winning in 2024
or desentis thank you in advance okay so
um
most damaging thing that biden has done
so i'm going to put this on three tracks
because i think that there are three
really really damaging things that he's
doing damaging thing number one
is that he came into office pledging to
be a unifying moderate and then he has
proceeded to polarize america along
racial lines with all this crap about
how
if you're in favor of voter id then it's
the same as jim crow and that is
radically exacerbating social problems
in the united states problem number two
is he's spending more money than has
ever yet been created by man or god
uh and that is going to have significant
downstream effects it's already having
inflationary effects right now
but reshifting the way that americans
think about the economy is a really bad
thing and it's going to have
real consequences over the next decade
or so including extraordinarily slow
growth
and finally i think that his entire
approach to foreign policy which seems
to be
to revivify connections with countries
that are terrible like iran
uh while kowtowing to china and russia
and pulling completely out of
afghanistan i know that there's a
position on the right that says pulling
out of afghanistan is a great idea
i just i don't understand that position
to be frank with you it does it doesn't
we're not talking about an active war
zone
we've had one combat casualty in
afghanistan over the last 18 months
it is more dangerous to be a cop in
chicago than it is to be a soldier an
american soldier in afghanistan these
days and keeping a small footprint there
to keep for example bagram air base that
we can launch airstrikes against the
taliban
seems to me significantly more important
than joe biden getting a very temporary
political win that isn't going to redown
by the way
in but you watch the date today it's
july 27th
we're supposed to be pulling out
basically within the next couple of
weeks i love it
when we announce military pull-outs too
that's always great that's always great
i guess we're supposed to pull out
completely by september 11th as though
this is some sort of win
which is amazing i mean like that is so
tone-deaf it's unbelievable so we're
going to hand back afghanistan on the
anniversary of september 11th to the
people who housed the people who
committed september 11th i just i
it's it's mind-boggling by the end of
november you're going to see mass
casualties
slaughter and the american people don't
pay attention to foreign policy until
they see ugly images on the tv which
means that by
my prediction by summer of next year we
will have troops in the quote unquote
advisory capacity back in afghanistan
all right next question comes from jeff
in illinois
as a teacher oh god bless you jeff what
is the best way to address
and debunk the debate of critical race
theory within the walls of the school
building so i think that the best way to
handle it if you are told to handle it
is to explain what critical race theory
is and then explain why it's wrong so
critical race theory's basic
notion is that neutral things like
individual rights
are actually just a cover for racial
superiority and inferiority and racial
hierarchies
i think that coming to grips with the
falsity of that pointing out that that
is not true
uh pointing it it's very easy to point
out that the evils of
american history are replicated nearly
everywhere else on earth
the good of american history is
replicated nearly nowhere else
on planet earth and that is a pretty
simple way of understanding
why it is that the united states is a
good country and was founded on good
principles even though the founders
very often did not live up to those
principles at the time how's your hand
doing
that's so far so good i mean this is i
signed like literally ten thousand book
plates the other day so yeah
i'm doing okay so far we're signing the
real deal right now guys
so you know get that ready i think i
have an ice bucket for you
at the end i don't know my husband uses
it when he's grilling on his green egg
but you know you i guess you can use it
when you're yeah but your husband is
like a pirate
eric is a pirate he's like a viking
pirate i think once you call them like a
lumber sexual
well that's clearly true because he's
like i saw a picture of him recently
yeah
he's got the beard and now he's got like
the he's he's more viking now he's got
like the long hair going i saw yeah it's
like how long is it like shoulder length
vikings mixed with miami vice
i think and your generous wife
hey you know what he brings home the
bacon
fair everyone else is up and also i mean
he's a very handsome viking man yes i
mean let's
and we make beautiful let's be real your
babies are very cute so we're staying in
california we're just going to be
fruitful and multiply and then hopefully
in 18 years the voting block is like
there yeah you're delusional but you
know enjoy
enjoy the ride all right i think we have
another third
authoritarian moment here we go
one of these days just gonna hit one of
us i know i'm actually afraid
elisha how'd you get that black eye it
was a scheme by the god king no
all right this one oh this comes
xi jinping yeah bad guy good times this
is this winnie the pooh over here
uh 100th year anniversary of the chinese
communist party you know the guy is
responsible for covet
let's take a look and the murder of 40
million people in the great leap forward
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
okay so yeah we had a bit of a mic
emergency there just to let you guys in
on the behind the scenes
this turned into a scene from um singing
in the rain like where lena lamont is
they're trying to hide the microphone
and uh and it's uh it's actually in the
bushes but then it's also like
in the bustle yeah good times you found
it though that's such a good movie
though it's a great movie gene kelly
all right p all right so talk about that
one
about oh sorry that's confused you want
me to sing like good morning no
no i really don't actually so yes i'd
rather talk about the communist chinese
party and i gotta say the audience is
like just get him to sign more books
that he should stop with the singing
yeah that
we're all like that very very often it's
been it's been so long alicia but in any
case
um yeah so there's winnie the pooh
riding down the street so the cheers of
throngs of people who are cuddled into
place if they
if they don't call xi jinping has
re-enshrined a dictatorship in china
in incredible ways his predecessor weng
chaibo
uh was was famously a person who was
supposedly attempting to open the
economy
and then it was going to reveal new
sort of open politics and it never
happened it turns out that the going
theory in the west which is that if you
provide economic benefit and free trade
into dictatorial countries that this
somehow makes them less dictatorial
remains an unproven theory uh and
instead it turns out they're weaponizing
capitalism against the west yeah they
just it's kind of like putin they just
give it to all their buddies and their
oligarchs until they send you to
siberian camp somewhere
all right next question comes from emil
in quebec city quebec canada
just like yourself i'm a huge fan of
western movies and
classical music which western movie
score is your favorite that's a good one
the best one is clearly magnificent
seven oh that is clearly the best
western
score although i do have a soft spot for
uh the dimitri tiankin score in a
gunfight at the okay corel because
it has one of those opening songs where
they where they actually
sing you know about the plot yeah i kind
of i kind of dig that
but yeah the the score to magnificent
seven is fantastic and elmer bernstein
is is the western composer it all sounds
like copeland by the way
that sounds like aaron copeland
interesting all right this comes from
kevin in tampa florida what is your
position
on global warming is it real or not and
given your reasoning as to why
also if it is real will it affect us in
the near future
okay so the answer is that by all
available data that i have seen
uh global warming is real uh even people
who are sort of lukewarmers acknowledge
the global warming's world there's
serious debate over how much
human activity is affecting global
warming and more importantly what we can
do
right now because once the carbon is in
the air it stays up there for ten
thousand years it ain't coming down
anytime soon
so the the kyoto protocols for example
if we had undertaken that it would have
really done very little to to actually
lower the trajectory of the climate
the same thing is true of the paris
accords which are going to do very
little the number one emitter on planet
earth by far right now is china
the united states has been lowering its
emissions because we have better
technology and natural gas
which the left doesn't like apparently
and i also don't like nuclear power
if we actually want to focus on
mitigating the effects of global warming
that's gonna be a lot easier and humans
are much better
at adapting rather than you know
changing entire ways of life
that have added enormous like
carbon-based fossil fuels i'm an
unbelievable boon to humanity and people
who don't have them are literally
burning dung in their homes right now
and then dying of the attendant diseases
so fossil fuels are great
the only problem is of course that this
does have an impact on the climate that
is a slow rolling impact that's going to
be felt over the course of the century
human beings have an excellent way of
adapting to this sort of stuff so if we
actually want to spend money on stuff
what we should be spending money on
is developments of technologies like
geoengineering to change the weather for
that worried about it
or developing technologies to start
carbon out of the air or building sea
walls or if you're worried about miami
being underwater we need to build some
more sea walls
because there are lots of cities in the
united states that exist below the sea
level
and the same thing is true you know all
over the world but there's this sort of
weird idea about global warming that
because the earth is gradually warming
over the course of the century
that we are going to see catastrophic
murder
by the environment of billions of people
or hundreds of millionaires are going to
die
right i mean and none of this has turned
out to be true in turn it turns out that
when people
see the weather changing they tend to
move they tend to leave
these particular areas and that's not
great i mean that's not ideal
but it also is what humans have done for
literally all of human history
i mean you'll recall that there used to
be an actual like bridge between
russia on this end and alaska right i
mean sarah palin could see it from her
house
and the and that no longer exists
because the climate is constantly
changing
and because the water level rises and
falls and you have icebergs that
exist you know 500 years ago that don't
exist now
and that's not the end of the world it
may not be
ideal for people who are living in
particular places but human beings are
great adaptation it's the one thing that
we are the best at we create
technologies we move we
we can change sort of how we how we live
what is really hard is to say to
everybody right now turn off your air
conditioner
stop driving your car stop using fossil
fuels and it's one thing to say that to
a bunch of ritchy riches in france and
the uk and the united states but you're
gonna say that's somebody who's living
in like djibouti
you're gonna seriously like you're gonna
go over to africa and you're gonna say
to people you know what you're living
online in like abject poverty what we
really need from you is to live in
abject poverty for like a long time
because at least your carbon emissions
are really low
like no that is not that is not a
solution all right next question comes
from rob
i i'm sorry rob i know you're in the
great state of georgia but i don't know
how to say your
your small town name and i'm going to
biff it so i'm not even going to try he
wants to know how can a young
college-age conservative begin to make a
difference in the cultural war okay so
if you are a college age conservative
you're now a reporter is what andrew
breitbart used to say you got a cell
phone you're a reporter there's a lot
happening on college campuses that needs
to be exposed
to the light of day and you can be one
of the people who does that there's a
lot of stuff that's newsworthy
a lot of taxpayer dollars are going into
those colleges a lot of parental dollars
are going into those colleges and the
colleges are a font of horrendous ideas
that affect the rest of the country so
become a reporter grab a cell phone and
get to work
and there's great organizations out
there like america's foundation we'll
print it yeah send us a story we'll
print it
that you're you're going to speak there
in a couple of weeks i am yeah yeah
i think next week and yeah thank you
or a great resource for you is fantastic
all right this question comes from
joshua in kokomo indiana that's funny
because when i think kokomo
i don't think indiana indiana all right
will america's institutions be 100
liberal by 2044. uh no there will just
be alternative institutions
if they all turn liberal there will be
alternative conservative institutions
and i will be a lot richer because
honestly like the way that this is going
to work is if
we end up with one conservative razor
company and one liberal razor company
i'm
ideally placed to start a conservative
razor company so like on a personal
financial level
then fine bring it but on a on a country
level i really hope that we can
back away from this because it is it's
not good that there should be like you
go to the store or
two separate stores and now we're just
completely segregated in terms of
politics that is not a good thing
also what about the people in the middle
yeah like where do they shop
yeah they buy two razors i'm not sure
next question comes from aiden in fort
worth texas he says hi
and what is your advice for young
conservatives and is it still worth it
to go to college excellent question
so when it comes to college if you're
not in a stem field i always start with
this if you're in a stem field yes it's
worth it to go to college you're going
to have an actual job connected to your
education right
my wife being a doctor it was good for
her to be in pre-med before she what
does she
she's a doctor oh wow no really it's
like it's a cool thing in fact i believe
that you've called her for advice on
occasion
she's my go-to yeah she's she's useful
um and uh
so if you're in stem field then yes if
you're in a what we call a north campus
major at ucla
meaning liberal arts poli-sci lesbian
dance theory
if you're in any of those things then
you should seriously consider whether it
is worth your money and your time and
you might see if you can find an
apprenticeship at a business that you
think is more
worthwhile if you can't then yeah you
should go get the college degree because
people still use credentialing
the real problem is not individuals
deciding to go to college the real
problem is that businesses need to
stop screening for college degrees right
now screening for college degrees is a
stupid thing
there are three business partners here
at daily wire two of the three did not
graduate college
yeah i i went to law school my both my
business partners did not graduate from
college
we don't screen for college degrees at
the daily wire if you're qualified
if you're qualified to do the job then
you're here right i mean that's that's
sort of the way that we approach it and
i think more businesses ought to
approach it that way all right the next
question comes from megan in dumfries
virginia she says that the country seems
to be so politically divided right now
and what suggestions do you have to help
bridge the gap between those on the left
and the right or do you believe that
returning to bipartisanship is even
possible so i think that so long as the
government remains a giant grab bag of
cash and power it's going to be very
difficult for bipartisanship to prevail
because it's just too big i mean
everybody is going to want to grab a
hold of that ring it's just
lord of the rings and whoever grabs a
hold of the ring doesn't want to let it
go
the way that you fix polarization is
really easy you find somebody you
disagree with and you say publicly
they're a human
i mean really it's that simple and i did
this the other day on twitter just as a
thought experiment i tweeted out like
you know if you really want to end
polarization what you could do is just
list people
who you who didn't vote like you did in
the last election and say they're a nice
person that you disagree with
but they're a nice person and you're
happy to read their work and i listed
off like 15 people
right people all the way to like van
jones on the left john lovett right of
positive america
none of the van might say something nice
about me because van actually has the
stones to stand up for this right he
worked with trump
um on on criminal justice reform did a
movie with megan mccain right exactly
like
man actually has the courage of of
trying to work across the aisle but
i don't think that you're ever going to
see somebody like john lovett say yeah
ben shapiro is somebody who i know as a
human being and is nice and and i
respect like
people just on the left i noticed that
there were a bunch of people on the
right
who followed up that tweet was like
here's my list i
couldn't find a blue checkmark lefty who
did it not one and then the thing was
retweeted like
30 000 times so yeah i think that's kind
of telling i i always do the uh
like the car tire rule that if you had a
flat tire on the side of the road who
would you trust to
help out your daughter and if you don't
have somebody
like that that you're friends with on
the other side of the aisle then that's
a problem yeah yep
all right next question comes from colin
in british columbia canada
what is your advice to young
conservatives like him but in canada
i mean they're dealing with a lot of
stuff right now specifically the tamping
down of oh you know religious gatherings
and
a very left-wing country and how can we
make a change that is right
for for traditional values in such a
woke culture that works to silence us
i mean i do think there's going to be
blowback in canada as well i mean the
conservative party's been in the
wilderness for a bit up there
but i think the blowback will begin i
mean stephen harper was a popular prime
minister there for a while
uh and i i think that the the left is
pushing so hard
so fast whether it's bill c-16 in
ontario uh or whether it's the crackdown
on religious freedom more broadly
i i think there can be a lot of people
in canada who eventually are just going
to say enough is enough i think it's
happening across the west by the way i
think it's why it's being manifested in
the rise of right-wing parties in europe
too
interesting and a little bit of pushback
with crt too yes like here in the states
all right next question comes from
mitchell in mount annan
new south wales australia he claims that
he's your number one fan from australia
i don't know he's gotten a lot of
australian fans writing in tonight but
maybe you are mitchell
he looks forward to reading your new
signed book and keep up the good work
mr shapiro nice
he was just giving me an encouraging
word i i appreciate that that's that's
because never has heard an encouraging
word
patrick from toledo ohio any advice
on how to write your first book to make
a stand in the culture
uh outline uh research uh yeah i've
written all of my own books which
you know can only be said for a few of
the authors in this particular space i
was i'm
gonna i was gonna give away some behind
the scenes that you've written a few
other books too yeah no
that that is not untrue um but it's but
i think that for for if you're not used
to writing you really do have to make an
outline and then you have to follow the
outline fairly closely so you have to
pre-think kind of where you're going
i've done it so much that i really don't
outline anymore like i can sit down and
i can just
write uh but that comes after years and
i've been doing this for nearly two days
and how many
best sellers uh let's see this would be
the fourth new york times bestseller
this one is number four but then there's
like another five that are under other
people's names
that i can't talk about contractually so
guys
can you believe that we're too like our
final question really
yeah wow i mean it's been fun and you
came all the way to florida just for
this
time flies when you're having fun and
the cuban food on the cuban food yeah
all right this comes from matthew in
mankato mankato minnesota since getting
elected
do you think that the president has
become a uniter
or a divider oh i mean he's been
incredibly divisive it's it's really
disturbing because again he was elected
to basically do two things be not donald
trump and be dead those were the two
things
and he by sense of the fact that he's
not donald trump is not donald trump
but he's not been quite as dead as i
think everybody was promised meaning
that
he is physically not alive but his his
sort of
take on politics has been extremely
polarizing he has
decided that it's very important to
define americans from americans for
political gain and he's decided that
since he is a one-term president
he's going to be incredibly active like
all the way through extremely active
uh and and that means he's going to ram
through as many things as humanly
possible
you can see it in the numbers by the way
his approval ratings are down pretty
significantly from when he was elected
and the the biggest number is that the
number of americans who say that they
are optimistic about the next 10 years
has radically shifted even a couple of
months ago almost two-thirds of
americans were saying they were
optimistic about where the country was
going over the next 10 years
and now is only about a third of
americans who say they're optimistic
about the next 10 years
all right so while ben signed some more
books
i promise i'm gonna not let him leave
here without like getting through all of
these guys
we have a pretty cool video from some
friends
yes he's not a robot he's friends
hey ben i'm about halfway through your
new book i gotta say it feels
like a big step down from your previous
work congratulations though what better
timing for a book about how the far left
is trying to silence dissent in america
everybody's got to read this because if
you don't understand what's going on
then you can't fight
and now is the time to fight
congratulations on the book release
it must have been a stealth release i
didn't hear anything about it on your
radio show or your podcast
i knew it was coming out because i
listened to the podcast every day so
as you people would say mazel tov
hey ben congrats on the new book i don't
know how you managed to write
nine books a year while it takes me nine
years to write one
you've done it again the east coast must
be good for you
hey ben it's brad thor congratulations
on the new book
if anybody knows how tough it is to
write one it's me i'm
really proud of you i know it's going to
be a huge success
well done keep crushing it hey shapiro i
just wanted to offer my deep
and sincere and heartfelt
congratulations on
the publication of whatever the hell
your book is called
and i hope the book release party is a
lot of fun and i hope
everybody has got four masks on just to
make sure
that everybody can be perfectly safe i
gotta tell you i'm i'm very excited to
read this book
because you've given me my campaign
slogan for 2028 knowles the
authoritarian moment so i'm sure it's
gonna be great i'm very much looking
forward to it and congratulations as
always
on another book with words you made
america smarter
wiser more ethical we've got a country
to save ben
as usual then you are right the left has
weaponized america's institutions
against dissent and i look forward to
spending time with you
in gulag 321 a b don't worry i'll bring
the cookies they'll be kosher
you doing okay yeah it was rougher than
i thought it'd be really
yeah i mean we didn't get through that
many it's like you know
i'm like an olympian who couldn't quite
make it through i just had to you know
i mean guys i'm the hostess with the
mostest i bring the ice bucket for that
it's kind of you i appreciate that the
writer's hand
all right so we're done but it's not too
late don't worry
you can still purchase your signed copy
of the authoritarian moment just head on
over to
dailywire.com ben and purchase your copy
for only 30 dollars you can get this
book
i should be on qvc you should you're
really good at this
make ben richer help him stay in florida
and pay less taxes
it's good to see you it's amazing to see
you as well thanks thank you
eventually you'll leave and escape and
if you don't then we'll have to
come and just maybe kick me out of the
studio i was like well fine then no no
not like that
i mean maybe we'll do that but you know
i just have a feeling this entire story
ends with
us like me descending in like snake
pliskin
into california to try and just take you
and eric and the children out
i just don't think it's gonna end well
in california you know my family we
already got like
the mad max thunder road mobile ready
that's true actually i don't need to say
that
that's teen on top that's true and maybe
who knows maybe governor larry elder
here's hoping it was good to see you
thank you everyone for tuning in to this
very special
live signing of the authoritarian moment
be sure to go to dailywire.com
ben to purchase your autographed copy
and maybe i will see you next time
you